compound butter lemon juice parsley
garlic bone
really good in this master class you'll
be able to gain even more knowledge
but more important more confidence in
becoming the cook that you want to be
we'll be working on techniques and
recipes focused on the belly from the
sea
and we're going to learn how to do
sous-vide cooking two different ways
and then one of my favorite courses in
any meal desserts
right out of the oven just like grandma
used to make
one of my first jobs was as a poisoner
and it was just an extraordinary moment
in my life
i got to work with so much fish there's
so much more variety of fish than there
is meat we're going to cook our bronzino
in salt crust i want you to hear it it's
oversold
it's a fish that has a very firm flesh
and therefore
it's not going to flake apart it's a
pretty easy fish to cook
to really get that skin crispy we want
to get all of that water off of there
you notice all the moisture that's
accumulating along my knife
beautiful this is something that i eat
maybe two or three days a week
[Music]
chocolate pot of creme it's a small
dessert but extremely rich
you could use a milk chocolate you can
even use a dark milk chocolate
my spoon goes in nice and gently look at
how smooth and creamy that is
i want you to be enriched in your
cooking technique and therefore be able
to nourish yourself
your friends and your family and you may
make a couple mistakes and that's okay
i've made countless mistakes but you
just keep moving forward
i'm thomas keller and this is my master
[Music]
class
[Music]
you